next let's talk about Donald Trump's
strongest moments during yesterday's
debate I know some people will see these
moments and they'll say David what's
strong about these moments I have to dig
pretty deep because Trump's performance
was so horrible but here are what I
believe were Trump's strongest moments
at least as they would be perceived by
the average voter let's take a look at
the first one so I know how to really
work to get new jobs and to get exports
that help to create more new jobs like
what you haven't done it in 30 years or
26 years laughter which was one of the
worst things that ever happened
Manufacturing Index you go to New
England you go to Ohio Pennsylvania you
go anywhere you want Secretary Clinton
and you will see devastation where
manufacturers down 30 40 sometimes 50
percent why was this strong well Trump
actually seemed to know what he was
talking about he at least listed places
New England and Pennsylvania etc that
have been impacted by bad trade deals as
he sees it the problem with this is that
Donald Trump is part of the reason why
many manufacturing jobs have been lost
Trump's own companies outsourcing to
China and to Mexico and also of course
many of those jobs no longer exist now
will anybody care about the details
probably not optically this was one of
Trump strongest moments another strong
moment for Trump was when Trump talked
about fighting Isis let's take a look at
that piece she's telling us how to fight
Isis just go to her website she tells
you how to fight Isis on a website
I don't think General Douglas MacArthur
would like that do much they Beck the
next segment we're continuing no no
you're telling the enemy everything you
want to do see you're telling the enemy
everything we want to do no wonder
you've been fighting no wonder you've
been fighting Isis your entire adult
life go to the please the fact checkers
go yeah so again this doesn't in any way
suggest that Donald Trump would be a
good president obviously he wouldn't in
it and it doesn't but optical
that was a strong moment and lastly
maybe Trump's strongest moment of the
entire debate a sort of pseudo attempt
at a takedown related to NATO take a
look the way they're going but when you
look at NATO
I was asked on a major show what do you
think of Danner and they have to
understand I'm a business person I did
really well but I have common sense and
I said well I'll tell you I haven't
given lots of thought to NATO but two
things number one the 28 countries of
NATO many of them aren't paying their
fair share number two and that bothers
me because we should be as we're
defending them and they should at least
be paying us what they're supposed to be
paying by treaty and contract and number
two I said and very strongly NATO could
be obsolete because and I was very
strong of this and it was actually
covered very accurately in the New York
Times which is unusual for the New York
Times to be honest but I said they do
not focus on terror and I was very
strong and I said it numerous times and
about four months ago I read on the
front page of The Wall Street Journal
that NATO is opening up a major terror
division and I think that's great and I
think we should get because we pay
approximately 73 percent of the cost of
NATO it's a lot of money to protect
other people but I'm all for NATO but I
said they have to focus on terror also
and they're going to do that and that
was believe me I'm not going to get
credit for it but that was largely
because of what I was saying and my
criticism of NATO I think we have to get
NATO to go into the Middle East with us
in addition to surrounding nations and
we have to knock the hell out of Isis
it's at least a specific critique it's
not really a policy idea and that
there's already this sort of
coordination in the way that Trump is
describing and we've exposed that before
but at least he seems like he knows what
he's talking about which he didn't for
most of this debate and at least there's
a specific critique and a somewhat
specific policy solution and I know the
bar is pretty low to figure out what
were Trump's best moments okay we will
take a break we are going to have more
coverage of this and more
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you
the opportunity to check out their
glasses I personally wear Warby Parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trialed comm slash TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing